[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome, everyone.
Thank you for joining us today
for the Apigee hybrid webinar.
A quick introduction--
today we're
going to be speaking about the
Apigee hybrid's launch, which
we launched a few weeks
ago at Next in beta.
And today Nandan-- who is
a product manager in Google
Cloud, and he's
the one who worked
on it the most-- is going to
be diving into all the details,
doing a demo, and speaking
about how Apigee hybrid fits
into the broader Apigee
offerings that we have.
Feel free to submit questions
at any point in time.
You can submit them right away.
And we will try to answer them
throughout the presentation,
as well as we have some
time set aside at the end
to answer those questions.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I am a product marketing
manager at Google Cloud.
And I'll be the host for today.
And I'm going to turn
it over to Nandan now.
Thank you.
NANDAN SRIDHAR: Thank
you so much, [INAUDIBLE]..
So let me give you guys a quick
overview of today's agenda.
I'll very briefly talk about
the Apigee API platform.
What are the
capabilities available?
And then talk about
what are the hybrid use
cases that we have seen
with customers so far
and what we have in
our current offerings,
and then talk about the
new offering that we have
and how it is different from
the current hybrid offering
that we have.
Then we'll talk about
some use cases, what
we've seen with customers
and some guidance
on when to use which
type of gateway.
So with that, let's start
a very brief introduction
to the Apigee API Platform.
I know to many of you,
you've seen these slides.
So I won't spend too
much time on them.
But it's always good to
start with a quick foundation
of where we are and
how this matches
with our current offering set.
So Apigee is a full lifecycle
API management product.
And obviously, what does
full life cycle mean?
It goes back to the beginning
of, what is an API lifecycle?
Any good API should
start with API design.
And if you had asked me a
couple of years ago API design,
I would have always said
open API specification--
that's all [INAUDIBLE] was
known a few years ago--
would have been a
great place to start.
But as we're seeing today, APIs
come in other shapes and sizes.
We're seeing a lot of GraphQL
being adopted by enterprises.
We are also seeing GRPC
as a popular form factor.
So API design now is more
than the Open API spec.
But fundamentally, the fact
that you start with a design
hasn't changed.
And then the natural
evolution of that
API is when you go into
developing that API,
securing that API,
and deploying it.
And it is really
deploy that we are
going to talk more about today.
Where do you deploy it?
What has changed
in the form factor
of where do you deploy is what
we are going to talk today.
The rest of the pieces
of publish, monitor,
analyze, and monetize
really hasn't changed.
But we'll briefly go over them
as we talk about deploying
APIs in multiple platforms.
So this is the
slide that we have
that talks about how Apigee
fits into a typical enterprise.
Your enterprise has many
types of applications.
You're probably building
your applications
with micro services.
You still carry a lot
of legacy applications,
and they will not
necessarily be moved.
And you're also consuming
APIs built by other vendors--
from Salesforce, from Workday,
from other SaaS providers.
And at the end of
it, API management
is super critical for
the consumption layer,
because at the end
of the day, what
you want to do is take all
these assets, these business
assets that you
have, and make them
available to your consumers.
So if I had to
succinctly put, what
does API management provide?
It manages the relationship
between providers
and consumers-- providers of
APIs and consumers of APIs.
So from that perspective,
we've got three or four
fundamental building blocks.
We've got the runtime.
We've got monitoring, analytics,
and of course, the developer
ecosystem.
So how do these impact
from a hybrid perspective?
Or what specifically
does it change
from a hybrid perspective?
Let's focus first
on the runtime.
From the runtime perspective,
we had three types of gateways
available today.
In the Cloud, as
well as on premises,
we had the enterprise gateway.
For hybrid, we had
microgateway and Istio
as the three types
of gateways that we
had available to customers.
From a mediation
perspective, this
is an API provider trying
to connect that API
to different sets of system.
The use cases that we saw
were security, transformation,
orchestration, abuse prevention,
and of course, extensions.
Some of these features
we introduced recently.
Take, for example, extensions.
We announced extensions
in the second quarter
of last year, which provides
developers with the ability
to connect to Cloud Services,
like data loss prevention,
to mask or obfuscate
the API content,
to connect to,
say, Google pub/sub
as an integration to
your messaging platform.
And now we have
started adding services
that are outside of GCP, like
with AWS and also Salesforce.
So extensions and
the runtime assets
are really providing those
tools to the developer
and improving the API
provider's productivity
by giving them tools
to build and connect
to different sets of APIs.
In the same vein, security
is also an important aspect
of exposing APIs.
You probably want to
do security mediation
because not all of
your applications
talk the same security language.
And it's important to
mediate between them.
So from a provider's
perspective,
as you're building
APIs, you also
want to be able to
monitor and analyze them.
And these are typically
different personas
that look at this.
The persona of a
production operator
is going to look at your
fleet-wide set of APIs
and look at, how are
all my APIs doing?
Are they throwing errors?
Are they measuring or
keeping up to the latency?
Is it not too high,
and things like that.
But as an API
provider, I don't care
about the fleet-wide
aspects of my API program.
I really care about APIs
that I have developed.
And for me, things
that are important
is, which is a consumer
that's consuming my API?
What type of client devices
are they connecting from?
If I am upgrading my API,
who gets impacted, and so on.
So different sets of personas,
but these are also critical
from an API
management perspective
that you have all this
data available to them.
And last-- and perhaps most
importantly-- all of this
is done to make the
consumers highly productive.
You want consumers to find a
single catalog of all the APIs
that are eligible to access.
And once they can access them,
that they can request access
to it.
And you, as a
provider, can manage
who or which of your consumers
can get access to these APIs,
how much of it can
they get, and so on.
So it really comes down to this.
The catalog of the portal
becomes that key place
where you manage that
relationship of consumers
coming in, hopefully some
service that they can auto
register, come in, see that
set of APIs that they have.
And you as a provider
are deciding how much
and whom you want
to grant access to.
And this follows
the fundamentals
of an API management platform.
So with this what
really has changed?
What we have seen
is that enterprises
are in a flux of moving
workloads from their data
centers to clouds.
And a lot of times,
it is lift and shift.
And in some cases, it's also
life, modernize, and shift.
So what does that mean
for API management?
What it means for us is
that in our enterprises,
we see that APIs are going
to be in multiple spaces.
Some APIs are going
to be on Cloud.
And usually enterprises are
picking more than one cloud
provider because they don't want
to put all their eggs in one
basket.
And there are going to be
some APIs that are never
going to leave on premises.
And on premises, our
data [INAUDIBLE] data
center footprint is
going to be a reality
for a lot of these enterprises.
And that's not going
to change, either.
So Apigee's current
offering, which is primarily
in two-fold, which is a
completely SaaS offering
or a completely on premises
offering with what customers
had the ability to pick from.
Now, the completely SaaS
offering, of course,
worked when you had
your workloads already
moved to the Cloud,
or if they already
remained in the data center.
And the Cloud platform
could route requests
either to one or
more Cloud providers
or to your data center.
For the enterprises
that were kind
of apprehensive about shifting
workloads to the Cloud,
they had the fully on
premises version of Apigee.
And then they could run
it in their data centers.
So what really changed?
What was missing?
One concern that
customers have expressed
with using a fully SaaS
offering was latency.
Imagine this use case where
your consumers and providers
are in the same
Cloud or data center.
You really don't want to
make a round trip all the way
to the Cloud to come back in.
What you want is to have a
gateway much closer to you.
From a security perspective,
some enterprises have standards
where certain API traffic cannot
leave their private networks.
And again, a Cloud
offering in that case
doesn't make sense
because you have your API
call leave your network.
So in both of these cases,
we would have told customers
that they could use Apigee's
on premises offering
and keep that traffic private.
The problem with using a fully
on premises version of Apigee
is that now there's an
overhead that customers
have to maintain-- the UI,
the RBAC, or the SSO for this.
They have to maintain
all of the analytics that
they're [? making ?] the
[? photo. ?] They have
to maintain really
the entire stack.
And what really they
were looking for
was the ability to keep the
gateways as close to the APIs
as possible and not
necessarily take
on the entire infrastructure.
So those are sort
of the beginnings
of why this was needed.
So Apigee had defined
API management.
And it started this in 2015.
And we'll show you
some examples of how
we did that of defining hybrid
API management as being this--
that there is an Apigee managed
control plane that is hosted by
and is maintained by
Apigee in the Cloud.
And then there's a
runtime plane that
is hosted, managed, maintained
by customers on other Cloud
providers or in their
own data centers.
And the runtime plane
contacted the control plane
to receive instructions
so it can operate it.
What this decoupled architecture
gave customers is the ability
to deploy just the gateways as
close to workloads as possible.
That way, latency was
no longer an issue.
API traffic never
left your network
and it could stay local.
And yet, you didn't
have the overhead
of taking the entire
infrastructure
and making it available.
So what really is part
of this management plane?
So the management plane
typically includes the UI.
It includes the RBAC for who can
do what even in the platform.
The UI can optionally
include the portal.
And I say optionally
because some customers
like to have custom portals
for various reasons.
And they should, of course,
continue to have that ability
to have custom portals.
And of course, the analytics--
I want to have these
gateways asynchronously send
analytics information
back to the control plane
where we can aggregate
this and create dashboards.
So that is hybrid
API management,
to have a decoupled management
and a runtime plane.
You'll notice that I
interchangeably use the word
management and control plane.
Yes.
There are some
subtle differences.
But for the purposes
of this conversation,
I will interchangeably use
those words, a management plane
or a control plane.
And then you have
the runtime plane
that can be distributed
running where ever, which
is receiving instructions
from this management place.
So Apigee had two offerings--
or has two offerings--
for hybrid.
In 2015, we launched
microgateway.
And microgateway
was specifically
addressing the need for an
API gateway for microservices.
When enterprises started
to build microservices--
and these are the really early
days of microservices in 2015--
they were looking for a very
lightweight gateway that
could do basic API protection
as close to the microservice
as possible, things like
API key verification,
OAuth verification,
[INAUDIBLE] were all
critically needed for the
API as close as possible.
A more centralized
gateway would have
mean that every one
of your microservices
would have to go through
the centralized gateway
and come back, incurring
a lot of latency
to your microservices.
So they really wanted a
lightweight gateway there.
And micro gateway continues to
be adopted by our enterprises.
And last year we did
a presentation with HP
where we talked about how HP
modernized their microservices
using microgateway.
So microgateway continues to
fill that segment of use cases
where it makes sense where you
have a-- where you are building
microservices and you need
a gateway as close to it
as possible.
Last year, Google
announced Istio.
Istio is as an open
source platform
that Google announced with other
partners like Red Hat, IBM,
and now there are many more
people like F5 networks,
and so on.
And Istio provides a service
mesh management infrastructure,
or a service mesh
infrastructure.
So Istio is meant to
manage your microservices.
It provides features
that a service operator
or a microservice
operator would care for,
things that you want built
into your infrastructure
so you don't want
every service developer
to think about, things
like MTLS, routing,
load balancing,
fundamental aspects
that not every service
developer should think about.
So as Istio service mesh
started becoming popular
and we're seeing
enterprises adopt Istio,
Istio provides a very
interesting capability.
It adds the notion of a
sidecar to every service
that you build.
And that's what you
see here as the proxy.
Now, when you already have a
sidecar associated with it,
Apigee said, well, this is
a very interesting use case
to do API management, as well.
The sidecar already exists.
And the sidecar is capable
of enforcing policies.
So what we did in 2018 was
to extend the capabilities
of Istio, make it knowledgeable
about Apigee policies,
such as same API key
verification, OAuth,
[INAUDIBLE],, and all that, and
have the site sidecar proxy
implement it or enforce it.
So in 2018, we launched
another hybrid offering
for enterprises that
have adopted Istio
to manage their microservices.
They now get an Istio that
is capable of Apigee API
management policies.
So what then changed?
We see that there's an
evolving set of use cases,
that customers, while
microgateway and Istio
certainly fit a certain
set of use cases,
customers really wanted the
capabilities of the enterprise
gateway available to them where
their APIs are without having
to go full fledged [? OPDK. ?]
So I've got my APIs in GCP.
I've got my APIs in Azure.
And I've got some APIs
in my data center.
And I want to manage
them the same way
I would do it in the Cloud.
So there are two fundamental
requirements that came up.
The first is that I want to
maintain my API proxy bundle
format.
So for those of you who
have been using Apigee,
you are familiar with
the API proxy bundle
format and all the policies
that are capable [? with-- ?]
that you can do with it.
And you know that microgateway
and Istio cannot do all
the policies that the
edge gateway does,
the gateway that you see in
the Cloud or that you see
[? in OPDK. ?]
So they give you a
limited set of policies.
But our customers
wanted all the policies
that Cloud had to
offer available to them
as close to the
APIs as possible.
The second, both
microgateway and Istio
use a YAML-based
declaration, which
means that you have
a different bundle
format between Cloud and
between your hybrid offerings.
And really what they wanted
was a universal common method
in which the same bundle
format should work for Cloud,
should work for hybrid,
should work on-prem.
And there should be no
differences between them.
And in response to this
evolving use cases,
really what they're
asking for is the ability
to take the enterprise gateway
that we have in the Cloud that
is capable of all this,
doing the same proxy bundles,
creating all the policies
that are available,
including the programmability
aspect of the edge gateway,
and have that
available as hybrid.
And that's exactly what Apigee
announced at Google Next
on the 9th of April, where we
have now in beta Apigee hybrid.
So although Apigee had
two hybrid offerings
in terms of
microgateway and Istio,
this is the Apigee
enterprise gateway
working in the hybrid mode.
Fundamentally or principally,
it works the same
as the other two gateways.
It still has a notion of a
centrally managed control
plane managed by Apigee.
So Apigee would be responsible
for the UI RBAC Analytics
portal, and so on.
And customers would be
responsible for the enterprise
gateway that is now decoupled
from the control plane.
And they can deploy
the enterprise gateway
in the data centers and other
Cloud providers, and so on.
There is an important
difference here.
This enterprise gateway is
available to be deployed only
on Kubernetes.
Now, we will discuss as we
go through the demo what
Kubernetes flavors and what
are the requirements are.
And we'll get into
[? details. ?]
But this is, again, a
change of how customers
would consume Apigee software.
Our [? OPDK ?] version, for
example, is available on VMs.
A hybrid is available
on containers
to be run on Kubernetes.
So when we talk about hybrid and
that there is a runtime plane,
obviously that
includes a gateway.
And this is the
enterprise gateway
that you would deploy on
your premises or other Cloud
providers on Kubernetes.
But what does this runtime
plane really contain?
What is it that
you, as a customer,
are responsible to
manage and operate,
assuming that Apigee takes
care of the management plane?
That's where you
define the policies.
That's where you create the
API products, and so on.
What is it that gets
shipped to customers?
There are four logical
components that are shipped.
The first is the
message processor.
This is the API Gateway.
For those of you
who have used OPDK,
you would see the
message processor.
That would be one of the
components that you installed.
And those of you who have
been using our SasS product,
you wouldn't know
this, but that's
what we call our gateways
inside as a message processor.
That's really the same gateway
that we've run in the Cloud
that you're now able
to deploy on premises.
What this means is that all
the proxy bundles that you've
built on Cloud or
on OPDK are fully
compatible with
the hybrid gateway.
They don't need to be changed.
The second piece that is shipped
along with the runtime plane
is an agent that is
able to replicate
data between the
management plane
and where your runtime
plane is deployed.
So let's take an example.
You have a developer.
Developer creates a proxy
in the management plane
and then deploys the proxy
to, say, the dev environment.
Now the agent is now
listening to any changes that
have been happening
to the dev environment
and now notices that there's
now a proxy available in dev,
will now make that proxy
available to the gateways that
are running on
premises or on Cloud.
And that is the job
of the synchronizer.
It has a certain
set of credentials
that allows it to access
only in the environment,
or in a set of environments
that you give it access
to, and is able to
pull information
like target servers, proxy
bundles, resource files, things
that you will create
artifacts that you create
in the management
plane and have them
made available to the gateways.
The third component
is Cassandra.
Again, our OPDK
customers would know
that Cassandra is the
persistence mechanism we use.
And we continue with it.
Cloud customers who are
not familiar with Cassandra
will be pleased to know
that Cassandra is also
deployed on Kubernetes.
So we get all the benefits
of Kubernetes here.
We have taken time to build
the operator model for this
so you can manage
Kubernetes in an easier way
than you would if you
had deployed them on VMs.
And lastly, there's
a component called
MART, which is an
admin server that
helps us manage certain
entities that are
required by the runtime plane.
The MART service is responsible
for managing entities,
such as API products, API keys,
access tokens, cache, KVM.
These are all entities that
are created by the runtime,
for the runtime, and MART
allows us to administer that.
So overall, these are
the four components
that a customer is responsible
for and that they manage.
And obviously the data
that is stored in Cassandra
never leaves the
customers' data center.
And it is-- or I should say
data center into your network,
because it could have been
in another Cloud provider.
But it's data that
you never leaves
your approved infrastructure.
So what happens from a
runtime architecture?
How do these get deployed?
What is the
architecture behind it?
OK.
So let's look under the hood and
see what actually gets shipped.
You'll notice that there
are a few more components.
These are supporting components.
And at the end of this,
I'll talk to you a bit
about the philosophy
of how we have
built the runtime architecture.
The first thing is that with
Apigee hybrid, Apigee ships
Istio.
Now, this is a version of Istio
that we have built into hybrid.
You don't have to
bring your own Istio.
It's not a separate thing.
It's an Istio version that
we ship, that we manage.
It's under the covers.
And the reason we use Istio
is because it solves a lot
of problems that we need--
solves the problem of doing
intelligent routing, load
balancing, key LS
termination, and so on.
So instead of us having
to reinvent that wheel,
we really love using
technology built
by our sister
organization in CSV.
And we are using it as
part of our architecture.
So what you're seeing
here, roughly each grey box
translates to a
pod in Kubernetes.
And of course, the Istio load
balance is the point of entry
into the runtime architecture.
The Istio load balancer
is load balancing
the request of the message
processes, which, again,
is another stateless
component that
is doing the proxying
before the call actually
goes to your service.
Supporting this infrastructure
are a few components
like synchronizer.
We talked about it.
It's the agent that makes proxy
bundles and other resources
available to the gateway.
Cassandra is where all the
runtime data is stored.
So the runtime data is as close
to the gateway as possible.
So it eliminates any latency.
We also talked about
the admin server MART
and that it is responsible
for managing certain artifacts
that the runtime relies on--
cache, KVM products, and so on.
And now let us talk a
bit about Analytics.
How does Analytics work?
So shipped along with
hybrid is an agent
that collects raw analytics
data from each of the gateways
and asynchronously
sends them to the Cloud.
So from your perspective as the
API producer or an ops person,
you're still going to use the
same Apigee user interface
as you always did to get all
the Analytics that you're used
to, that you're accustomed to.
You would not see any difference
between where the gateway is
actually deployed.
It so happens that some of
these message processors
are deployed outside of Apigee.
But from your perspective,
you get common analytics.
And the way it happens
is through this agent
that is able to collect
raw analytics data
and send it back to the crowd.
But a lot of our customers have
asked if they can also get,
or if they can also tap
into this raw analytics
information for their own data
warehousing and BI processing.
And this is not possible without
you having to export data out
of Apigee again.
The agent is capable of sending
raw analytics information
to more than one destination.
One of those destinations
would, of course, be Apigee.
The second destination could
be something of your choice.
You could use GCS, S3, whatever
is your favorite data lake.
It can be routed there.
And now you have a copy of
the raw analytics, as well.
So the overall architecture
of what gets deployed
are these components.
And it follows a fundamental
philosophy of open fail
or fail open.
What does that mean?
You will notice that all the
critical pieces for the success
of your API call is all
available at the infrastructure
that you manage.
Should you lose
connectivity to the Cloud--
so that's two components, MART
and synchronizer that kind
of tether to the Cloud--
are not able to tether to the
Cloud for whatever network
failure or other problems
that you may have,
all the information that the
gateway needs to continue
processing APIs are
already available
and you won't
notice any failures.
Yes, it is true,
that you won't be
able to deploy a new
proxy at that point
or create a new cache or a KVM.
But any information
that already made it
through before the failure
is already present.
And this is very critical
when running mission
critical applications on Apigee
that a constant tether is not
necessary for your
processing of APIs.
SPEAKER 1: We actually
have a few questions
on the architecture.
So why don't we take a
couple of them right now.
One is, is router
and Istio the same?
So I presume the person
who ask this question is
familiar with OPDK.
The job off the router
that we had in OPDK
is now replaced by Istio's
Ingress Gateway, yes.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
NANDAN SRIDHAR: But it does
more than what the router did.
So it, of course, does
what the router did.
And now it does a lot more.
And my following slides
will explain what
the additional features are.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Does Cassandra and runtime
architecture used--
is it used only for
caching, or is it
also temporary
storage for analytics
before they are
pushed to the Cloud?
NANDAN SRIDHAR: Casandra
is not used for analytics.
So Cassandra is used for
the following use cases--
API products are there,
access tokens, API keys,
cache KVM are the entities
that are stored in Cassandra.
Nothing else is stored there.
And this data that
I'm talking about,
which is, again, cache KBM,
access tokens, keys, products,
and all that is only
stored in Cassandra.
There is no copy of that
maintained in the Cloud.
So this data is only persisted
in the customer's Cassandra.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Is there TLS between all
the runtime components
deployed in my data center?
NANDAN SRIDHAR: Yes.
All components have TLS or
MTLS, [? your ?] option.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
NANDAN SRIDHAR: At least
one ATLS is mandatory.
Two ATLS is up to you.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Let's move on, and
we'll come back
to the rest of the
questions at the end.
NANDAN SRIDHAR: All right, so
what actually gets deployed,
and how are they
deployed on Kubernetes?
Like I said, the
runtime architecture
depends on Kubernetes.
It is not available on a
non-Kubernetes platform.
And the reason for
that is we don't
want to reinvent a
lot of the goodness
that Kubernetes brings
with respect to upgrades,
or autoscaling, and things
like that that are already
built into the platform.
And no point in us trying
to reinvent that wheel.
So most of the applications
that we deliver
are stateless, including
the synchronizer, which
is replicating data
you [INAUDIBLE],,
and you bring up another.
It's going to pull
the data again.
So effectively, it is stateless.
The important thing that
is stateful is Cassandra.
Cassandra is a stateful set.
And part of the architecture
relies on at least Kubernetes
1.10 or higher.
So if you are on a lower
version of Kubernetes,
you may want to think about
creating a new cluster that is
at least 1.10 or higher.
Now, of course, you
will get more benefits
when you're going to some
of the higher versions,
but this is the minimum
version that we are targeting.
Now we've taken
some important steps
here to make the operations
of these components
much easier, right?
So, of course, they all use
the horizontal part autoscaler
of the stateless components.
And when you are dealing
with a stateful component
like Cassandra, we are
building automated backup.
And these automated
backup primarily
work when you're
running in other clouds
like GCP, AWS, or Azure,
because they provide us
with some capabilities that
we can rely on to exist.
And so you, as a
production operator,
can configure these
automatic backup tasks.
So we can take
backup of Cassandra
and store it into,
say, SV or GCS,
depending on where
you are running.
So these are the
architectural details
of how we are deploying
this on Kubernetes.
Again, if there are questions,
we can come back to it
at a later point in time.
All right.
What we're going
to do now is we're
going to do a demo, because
I talked to you a bit
about the architecture.
It makes sense now for you to
see it, see the demo in action.
And then we'll come
back to some slides
and I'll walk you through
some more architectural bits.
And they'll start to
make sense once you
see the demonstration, right?
And that may also give
you the opportunity
to ask other questions
based on using the demo.
And those questions will
come towards the end.
OK, so let's start
with the demo, OK?
Let me quickly walk you
through the setup that I have.
I've got two clusters here.
And, of course,
I'm using GKE here.
I've got one cluster,
Apigee, and that already
has everything configured.
Everything is set up.
But that's not the demo
I want to show you.
The demo I want to show you
is a cluster that I've got,
which is Webinar.
And you'll notice here,
when I click on workloads,
all the things that I've created
are on the Apigee clusters.
The webinar cluster
is completely empty.
Right, and what I want to
show you today is first,
how did I set up this cluster?
What are some of
the best practices
when you set up clusters?
And then going from 0 to 60.
All I have is an empty cluster
and I want to get hybrid going.
How quick is that?
What does it mean for me?
So take a minute
to spend about what
is it that I have done to my
Apigee, to my GKE clutsers.
So on this Webinar
cluster, you'll
notice that I've
got two node pools.
I've got a node pool
for the runtime,
which I've got three nodes for.
And I've got one separate
node pool for the data,
for my stateful set,
which is Cassandra.
Usually what we would recommend
is that your stateful set
has a high speed data.
So either a local storage
class or a local with SSD
would be ideal from a
performance perspective.
Your runtime is a stateless.
It can be its own node pool.
And obviously, they can scale
independently of each other.
Ah, zoom in.
Right, is this better?
Cool.
You also notice that I've
got something interesting
going on here with
respect to leveraging
Secrets and encrypting them.
With [? hybrid-- ?]
and we'll go into this,
into some more detail--
I've got to slide on this.
A lot of the application
Secrets like encryption keys,
your [? not-bound ?]
TLS certificates,
and so on, are leveraging
Kubernetes Secrets.
And when you leverage
Kubernetes Secrets
on platforms such
as GKE, you could
use something like an HSM
or KMS as the repository
for where these are stored.
And these are then
made available to this.
So anybody in industries
where they're highly
regulated, the ability to store
such sensitive data on an HSM
will be very useful.
So I turned this on so you
can see how that works.
So very, very briefly,
that's what I've got.
I've got a single node, or
a single region cluster.
And I'm going to set
up Apigee on this--
the hybrid on this.
The second piece
I want to bring up
is that there is
a YAML file where
you specify the details
of, what is it that you
want installed on this cluster?
Because while you have
these four components,
they don't necessarily all have
to go into the same cluster.
You could move
your stateful text
to one cluster, your stateless
components to another cluster,
and so on.
Given that flexibility, you need
some sort of a configuration
file to know where goes what.
So here is a YAML
file that I've got,
which we call the
overrides.YAML.
And I've specified
in it certain details
about, for example, what is
the credentials I need to pull
the images, the docket images.
First, we signed all
our docket images
and then made
available in Docker Hub
so you can configure your
cluster to trust images that
are only signed by us.
Second, you specify things
like what certificates
to use for my runtime,
what certificates
to use for Cassandra,
whether you want MTLS or TLS.
These are all things that you
specify in this overrides file.
Now, a lot of these details
I have explicitly said.
Not all of them are
needed if you're doing
a very simple POC-type install.
You can skip a lot
of these details.
And we assume some defaults,
which are not always
acceptable for a
production deployment.
So I've got this
overrides.YAML that
are specified for each component
what it is that I want.
What happens next?
Now I'm going to
switch to my terminal.
And I'm going to walk you
through what happens next.
Apigee has shipped a utility
called Apigee Cuttle, right,
kind of sticking with
the theme of Cue Cuttle,
and Istio Cuttle.
There's now Apigee
Cuttle that helps
you manage the deployments
to the Kubernetes cluster.
Now I know some
enterprises will use Helm.
Some will use customize.
Some will use a whole bunch
of other tools to manage it.
And therefore, this
is an optional tool.
It is a tool that can help
you, at least initially,
to understand how we generate
the Kubernetes manifests.
So I use Apigee Cuttle and
pass the overrides.YAML.
This allows me to create
a Kubernetes manifest.
Now, if I run Apigee Cuttle
with a drive-on setting,
then it will only generate
the Kubernetes manifest
and not actually deploy it.
You can, at this point,
customize it, change it,
make other things
to it, and maintain
your own set of
Kubernetes manifests
that you can deploy later.
And you can go into
the folder beta,
you'll notice that we
use [? Go ?] templating,
which is kind of what other
standards like Helm also use.
So it is very similar
from that perspective
of what we have followed.
But because not every
enterprise will have Helm--
nor should we assume
that everybody has Helm--
this utility is handy
to get you started.
What I've done is I
have, in my shell script,
written a couple of lines of
code that set up the namespace,
create the docker, and
then run this command
to apply the overrides.YAML
on my cluster.
So that is what I'm
going to do now.
I'm going to hit setup.
And this is going to do it.
And what we're going
to do at the bottom
is start to watch what happens.
And you'll notice below
that all these parts
are getting created.
And we're going to give it about
a minute for this to finish,
right?
And, in the meanwhile, while
we wait for these clusters
to set up, let's
take a few questions.
The whole setup takes about
three, four minutes-ish,
give or take.
And at that point,
we'll go back.
And now I'll walk
you through what
I'm going to do next, which
is to actually test it.
So all I did was create
a cluster, a completely
empty cluster, I had
nothing else on it.
I had a YAML file
where I declared
what is it I wanted installed on
my cluster, how many replicas,
and so on.
And I ran my command.
And now I'm going
to let Kubernetes do
its thing of setting this up.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
NANDAN SRIDHAR: OK, [? she ?]
[? got ?] some questions?
SPEAKER 1: Yep, I actually
see a bunch of questions
on the Kubernetes piece.
And I think one theme is,
can runtime be deployed
on Anthos, GK on-prem, AWS EKS?
NANDAN SRIDHAR: Yes.
The answer to all
of them is a yes.
In fact, on Anthos,
there is a slide
that is going to come
up of how we integrate
with Athos specifically.
And that should
cover GKE on-prem.
But EKS, AKS, all
supported, yes.
SPEAKER 1: OK, great.
Can you run the containerised
runtime environment
on other container orchestration
environments like ECS?
NANDAN SRIDHAR: Yes.
ECS is a no, same for
Cloud Foundry is a no.
At the moment they have
to be Kubernetes based.
SPEAKER 1: OK, great.
Are you replacing microgateway
with this new runtime?
NANDAN SRIDHAR: No, I think
microgateway fills a use
case for microservices that the
Enterprise gateway doesn't and
that will continue.
In fact, I see microgateway
working in conjunction
with the Enterprise gateway
where, for your microservices,
you continue to use this.
And for other
services, you could
use the Enterprise gateway.
SPEAKER 1: There are also
a few different questions
around existing customers
who are either using OPDK
or the [? fast ?] solution.
Can you talk in
general about how
someone who's using OPDK
today could try out hybrid
and how that would work?
And, similarly, for
this [? fast ?] version.
NANDAN SRIDHAR: Right.
So to try out the
product, of course,
please contact your account rep.
And then we can work with
the account rep to sort
of provision an [? arch. ?]
You'll notice that,
in the documentation-- and
I'll show you the documentation
in a minute--
which talks about all the
prereqs that are needed.
And one of the prereqs is that
you need a hybrid-enabled org
to be created in the Cloud.
And once you have that,
once that org is created,
then you can try out a hybrid.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
And in that--
I think there's a question
about where the orgs are,
if they can be on private Cloud
or if they can be public cloud?
SPEAKER 1: Given that the
management plane is always
Apigee managed, you're org will
always be created in the Cloud
by Apigee.
And once you have that
hybrid-enabled org,
you can try hybrid.
SPEAKER 1: OK, great.
NANDAN SRIDHAR: OK,
so it took me about,
roughly two or three minutes
to have the set up completed.
You notice very quickly
here, we've got Cassandra.
And then we've
got some jobs that
create the Cassandra key
spaces, the users, and so on.
We've got logging, and I'll
come to that in a minute.
I've got my synchronizer
pieces running.
I also have my message
processor here.
It's called [? MT. ?]
And that's running.
All my pieces are, more or
less, good to go and running.
So at this point,
let me see if I've
gotten a public IP address.
And once I have my
public IP available,
I should be able to try this.
Right, so let's go to cluster.
And let's go to Webinar.
And let's wait for this.
All right, I've got my
public IP also available.
So this is the IP
address that, because I'm
running on the Cloud, I can use
the service type load balancer.
And it automatically creates
a load balancer for me.
If you're running
this on premises,
then you would use a
node port mechanism.
And then you would have
something like an F5 load
balancer in front of it.
And that would act as
the inbound IP address
to your message processors.
So, at this point, I'm
going to copy this.
But before I actually
run something,
I'm going to show you
a couple of things, OK?
I will demo one.
OK.
Let me go to API proxy here.
And I had a sample
proxy deployed.
This is the hello word that
comes with every [? arch. ?]
And this is what I had deployed.
And you'll notice here that
the parts are asynchronously
sending deployment status
back to the control plane.
So when I deploy something,
they asynchronously communicate.
Did that deployment complete?
Now, I take a minute
after I show you
my [? go ?] command, what
actually happens here
with respect to deployment.
So bear with me.
Let's quickly try it.
I've got a sample proxy there.
So I'm going to
hit the [? go. ?]
And I'm going to--
oops, I didn't copy it.
So let's go copy this.
[? Put it ?] here,
[? NV0 ?] hello, minus K,
because I use a
[? self-find ?] cert.
And I got "Hello, guest" back.
So my proxy's already
got the deployed, right?
So now let's see what
actually happened,
and how does this change.
How does your
developer flow change?
In this org, I've got a bunch
of APIs proxies deployed.
And I'm going to
deploy one now so I can
show you what actually happens.
And then we'll switch
to the analytics view
and see what happens there.
All right, and I'm
going to actually
deploy this API proxy to this
other cluster that I have.
Deployments are
now asynchronous.
It's really you're submitting
a request for deployments.
Because the gateways
are no longer
attached to the control plane.
What we've effectively done
is submit a job to [? say, ?]
deploy this.
And now the synchronizer, which
is listening to these events,
will eventually--
it pulls every 60 seconds.
That's the pull
interval I set up.
And so, within 60 seconds, it's
going to listen to this change,
make it available
to the gateway,
and then communicate that
response all the way back.
At which point, I will know
that the API proxy was deployed.
So we'll give this
another 30, 40 seconds
to see the deployment
went through.
But we'll come back to
this page in a second.
Let's look at a few
other components.
This hybrid, we've taken
some important changes
to the architecture.
Oh, there you go.
It reported that the
deployment was successful.
You'll notice that the
change was asynchronous.
All right, that's good.
That was something
I wanted to show you
guys of how
deployments work, which
is going to be different from
how you typically did this.
OK, let's quickly take a look
at some important changes
that we have done from an
architecture perspective.
If you look at the
workloads, you'll
notice that we are shipping
a few other pieces which
are new components that are
shipped as part of Apigee.
Let's pick the webinar cluster.
Here we have a few
components called metrics,
and then we have logger.
Right?
So with metrics, Apigee
ships Prometheus.
And Prometheus is
important for two reasons.
First, Prometheus
because the relay point.
From there, we push
all the analytics
to Stackdriver metrics.
Now Stackdriver metrics will
be offered as part of Apigee,
or Apigee hybrid.
This is not a separate thing
that you have to go get.
But it will be included as
part of Apigee Monitoring.
So you get basic
alerting, monitoring,
all those things
that you would have
needed to manage your runtime
are included with this.
Stackdriver automatically
gives us these capabilities,
and those are included
in the platform.
The second piece
is that we include
the Apigee [? Logger, ?]
which automatically sends
logs to Stackdriver.
Again, all the logs from your
gateways, from your Cassandra
and everything
else automatically
goes to Stackdriver, where you
get a robust logging search
mechanism that is already
shipped as part of the product.
Having said that, these
may not necessarily
be your Enterprise standards.
And if you had an Enterprise
standard to, say, AB Dynamics,
New Relic, or something
else, then, by all means,
you should be able to
configure those as well.
Because we use Prometheus
as our relay system,
you could use
Prometheus as a point.
From there, New Relic, or AB
Dynamics or something else
picks it up from there.
Because we use something
like [? Fluende ?]
to ship data back
to Stackdriver,
that could be the
point where you also
add a [INAUDIBLE] ship logs
to other platforms as well.
So, while Apigee will certainly
be opinionated and provide
these dashboards through
a Google GCP-centric
view of Stackdriver
logging in metrics,
you're free to configure
other platforms as well.
What happens with environments
and load balancing and routing?
And this is part of the reason
why we introduce something
like Istio.
With hybrid, we want to
[? stop ?] environments
as more as SDLC
platform where you have
a dev, a QA, a test, and so on.
We have to start thinking
of environment as sandboxes.
Why is that?
Well, we've shrunk the size
of the method processors
so it can be containerized.
And you can run multiple
parts in the same worker
node in Kubernetes.
Second, we've made
environments self-serviceable
so you can create as many
environments as you want.
So the environments have
now become sandboxes.
So create many environments.
If you're running
production, create
prod-one, prod-two, prod-three,
prod-four, and so on,
many environments.
And each environment as
sandbox which contains
proxies of similar workload.
So now you don't have a
noisy neighbor situation.
One proxy gets massive
amount of traffic.
Other proxies are not being
autoscaled as a result.
It's only that proxy that is.
Now, in the previous
model, the challenge
with having many environments
means that your virtual host
is also many.
And that's a type of user
experience you don't want
to have, prod-one.API.com,
prod-two.API.com, and so on.
But with the load balancing
that we're doing with Istio,
we are now able to make
it intelligent enough
where the load balancer
is able to send
that request to the
appropriate environment, right?
So, although you have
many environments,
they will have the same domain
name, or the same virtual host,
to which they access their APIs.
So you get your isolation.
You get the scaling
that you need,
while not having to reveal some
of these infrastructure details
to your consumer.
A question I get
asked a lot is, hey,
I'm not using Istio
as my ingress.
I'm using something else.
What happens?
Well, first off, to
be pedantic, it still
doesn't use the
ingress notation,
it uses a gateway notation.
So it's not really an ingress
from that perspective.
But feel free to add something
else on top of the Istio
ingress, like an F5 load
balancer or something else.
But the Istio ingress is a
part of the Apigee install.
We control it.
And we need that
to be there to be
able to do some of this
intelligence self-balancing
that we do.
Two, the TLS search and keys
that are used for the ingress
are sorted in
Kubernetes Secrets.
So that's not
information that even
comes to the control plane.
Now, we talked a bit
about Secrets management.
Secrets are used in a
number of instances.
We use Secrets to
store encryption keys
for your encrypted KVM.
We also use encryption
keys to encrypt your cache.
All of these secrets are now
in the Kubernetes Secret.
And in the example
I showed with GKE,
I used an HSM to store
my encryption key.
Also, your TLS secrets
are stored there.
And if you're using
Kubernetes 1.13,
all the information in
[? SCD ?] is also encrypted.
How would multi-region
expansion work?
Well, most of these
components are stateless.
The only stateful
thing is Cassandra.
And you would expand this by
creating additional clusters
and creating a ring that
expands multiple regions.
All right, so now we've
got three options, right?
We've got microgateway.
We've got the Istio Adapter.
And we've got hybrid.
What option is right for you?
So, first off, let's understand
what features are there
in the Apigee platform and
what's available in hybrid.
It is Apigee's goal to
make Apigee hybrid feature
equivalent to Cloud.
It shouldn't matter who
manages your runtime, Apigee
or our customers.
All the features that
you get in the Cloud,
you should get with hybrid.
Some of these examples, like
bot detection or [? holstered ?]
targets, are currently
not available
in our on-premises version,
only available in Cloud.
But with hybrid, all
of these features
will eventually be available
with hybrid as well.
So with that, here's
a quick summary.
And I'm not going to
draw too much into this.
We'll make available these
slides through the webinar.
So you will have access
to this information.
But I'm going to quickly
go through, because we
are running out of time here.
Let me very quickly give you
some guidance on what you pick
[? when. ?] The first
question you need to ask
is, do you want SaaS or hybrid?
Which is, do you really want
to manage anything at all,
or do you want to let Apigee
manage all the infrastructure?
If hybrid is the answer, then
the next question becomes,
well, what are you trying
to manage the APIs for?
Are they for
microservices, or are they
for a mix of old and new?
So if it is just
microservices, then you
could use either microgateway
or Istio, if you're using Istio.
And then that becomes
your choice of gateway.
If your policies are going
to be more complicated
than that, where you want
to have all the advanced
features of the
Apigee Edge platform,
then Apigee hybrid would be
the right answer for you.
So this is a very,
very high level view.
I'm positive that,
when you actually
get into individual
customers scenarios,
there'll be more
questions than this.
I'm going to take 30
seconds to talk about Anthos
and how we run with Anthos.
Anthos ships with GKE,
eventually with CSM and Cloud
Run.
Apigee would be what's
on top of GKE on-prem.
And eventually, we'd be looking
for integration with CSM
and other parts
of Anthos as well.
So, immediately, we definitely
support GKE and GKE on-prem.
That's our integration
with Anthos.
And over the period of time,
we will support other features
as they become GA.
CSM is not GA yet.
So Cloud Services management,
which is managed with Istio.
When it becomes GA, we will
start integration with it
as well.
So with that, I'm going to pause
now and go back to [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER 1: OK, great.
As you know, weve run out
of time for questions.
So here's what we'll do-- you
can email your questions, which
is apigee@google.com Free
to email questions there.
Also, if you want to try
out Apigee hybrid in beta,
feel free to send
an email there.
What we will do is we'll
take all of these questions.
There's some great questions.
We'll make sure that our Docs
team has access to those.
And they will try their
best to incorporate that
into the documentation.
And feel free to post
on the community.
I think there's some questions
on the community as well.
We'll go through and
answer those there.
And with that, thank you so
much for joining us today
and for asking some
great questions.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]